good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
currently colder in indianapolis than it
is on most of mars
all right Hank I gotta go I think
Willie's stuck Free Willy also I
strained my groin so I'm literally
sitting right now on a bag of frozen
organic strawberries so in general my
life is dominated by cold let's talk
about warmth Los Angeles is warm that's
where they make in The Fault in Our
Stars movie this is the poster in case
you haven't seen it I love it
I particularly love it because I can't
remember the last time I saw a movie
poster with a female romantic lead who
has visible evidence of her physical
disability but is still portrayed as
being able to like love and be loved so
that's great boy I hope the movies good
I haven't seen it yet but it should be
good all right what else makes me feel
warm mmm ester so I guess to Earl was
our friend and a nerdfighter who died of
cancer when she was 16 she inspired much
of the Fault in Our Stars but The Fault
in Our Stars isn't about her this is her
actual story it's an amazing book Esther
was a beautiful writer I wrote the
introduction and other people run other
parts but Esther's parts of the best
I'll read you the first sentence of my
introduction by the way there's a link
in the doobly-doo you can pre-order it
comes out January 28th my friendship
with Esther Earl began as so many great
love stories do at a Harry Potter
convention also there's a big book
launch event on February 1st in Boston
with lots of nerdfighters and wizard
Rutgers and Esther's family there's a
link in the doobly-doo and it will be
live streamed here at youtube.com slash
vlogbrothers mmm what else is warm
American president Millard Fillmore was
born this day in 1800 the last thing he
ever ate was one spoonful of warm soup
so that's warm oh and also of course
England in winter is very warm what's
that oh well at least it's dry oh I see
okay that sucks but it warms me on the
inside to be able to tell you that the
nerdfighter community is now officially
a sponsor of AFC Wimbledon a football
club owned by its fans this saturday AFC
wimbledon play torque a torque we torque
why Torquay not very good at
pronunciation
anyway they play one of the other teams
and we do and our messages will be on
the side of the field and in the program
so nerdfighters of Kingston and
Wimbledon and Greater London I hope that
you will find a way to go to the game
because I think it would be great if
they were nerdfighters support for the
first official nerdfighter game there is
a link to the location of cherry red
record stadium in the doobly-doo and if
you don't know what I'm talking about
should watch this video so there you
have it Hank Esther's dream of being a
published writer is really going to come
true and we sponsor a fourth tier
English professional soccer team life
and nerdfighteria continues to be weird
and wonderful well sometimes other times
you have to sit on frozen organic
strawberries but at least they're
organic
no conventionally farmed strawberries
for my groin Hank I'll see you on Friday